now you mentioned some of the nba
players
you know talking about this yesterday
athletes across a number of sports
coaches
across a number of sports
commenting on this and why wouldn't they
i mean it's an issue i keep saying it's
an issue of democracy if you care about
democracy if you don't care about
democracy you'll take a side and you'll
find a way to to break this down along
uh racial lines or to break this down
along political lines but that's not it
this is it's that that's not the real
story but i wonder what the athletes
will do
because it's interesting
with george floyd
8 minutes and 46 seconds
everybody saw that on video
and
you could say you could say this is
unacceptable
you could say
black lives matter
and you wouldn't have to prove
i'm not to be not to be cynical here but
you don't necessarily have to prove
what your intentions are or how
authentic you are with that if you say
if you see this video and you say this
video is unacceptable we should not be
dealing with this united states black
lives matter you could keep going
without that declaration i asked for
earlier but now you must declare because
if you look at what daniel cameron did
yesterday and how he hid
how he hid behind a law that is unjust
and pretty much threw up his hands and
said there's nothing i could do right is
what it is right
if you okay now it's very difficult
there are a lot of
there are a lot of nba owners
who are donors to the republican party
and there are a lot of
there are a lot of republicans who don't
think this is an issue
so now you've got to choose you've got
you've got to make a decision you've got
lebron james and jaylen brown and george
hill and fred vanvleet coming at you
saying okay
i need your help right now i need your
help i need you to exercise the power
that you have in that realm
can you help us
because now you can't hide
if you don't help them you've already
said where you stand
and this is where nba players have great
leverage and and i hate to even say it
like this mike because i want to be
clear
i'm so proud of of the modern athlete
the modern athlete has gone far
far above
any other athlete of any other
generation right now
with their activism their thoughtfulness
and continuing to use the platform that
they have more than before
i was going to say athletes but beyond
athletes
who else is doing this
are are actors across the board doing
what nba players are doing
are musicians
and not to say they're required to but
i'm just pointing out that athletes
we're looking at athletes to see how
they respond
and that's almost backwards
i'm glad they're doing it but but they
weren't hired to do that right they
weren't hired to do this but they're
doing it anyway right the people you
hire to do this
are not doing it
it's not just athletes it's not just
entertainers no no hold on let's let's
let's stay with that let's unpack that
for a second because i know you know
i'm
i'm venting
you know where i'm expressing my anger
i'm expressing my frustration
i don't have the answers i don't have
the solutions but then i ask myself a
question why the hell should i
it's not on any it's not on black people
to fix a problem we didn't create
we are not we are not the originators
and the developers and the builders of
this systemic systemically racist system
so we listen the alternative is just to
accept it so of course we have to we
have to organize strategize and mobilize
and we got gotta fight of course i'm not
saying we do nothing
but the fact that it's on this this is a
government ostensibly in theory this is
a government for the people and by the
people
for what people and buy what people
when you talk about declaring what sides
you're on
like we don't we can't be the only ones
who are in a perpetual state of rage
baldwin said to be black and relatively
conscious is to be in a perpetual state
of rage why are for the most part for
the most part and the beautiful thing
about these protests since george
floyd's murder yeah you've seen a
coalition come together it's been a
beautiful thing there seems to be an
awakening
a desire for a reckoning not a true
reckoning but an awakening
and an activation of activation among
you know more of a diverse people than
you've seen in in recent years
that said why do you have to be black in
order to be a in a perpetual state of
rage you know about brianna taylor you
don't you don't you don't you don't you
don't we didn't we didn't create this
problem so to look to athletes to look
at any black people to come up with
solutions and answers to this but even
we need help we've been saying okay we
need help
you're right you're right
we know
we didn't create the problem
and that's true what you're saying is
true but it's not even
that deep
it's not even that deep
it's
you're living in a country
you're living in a country
someone was murdered
at midnight
in her house
and
no one was held accountable for that
murder
now if you think
you've got to be black to be angry at
that i don't know what kind of what kind
of helicopter what kind of hell of
democracy is that is that a democracy
like are you are you alive are you awake
are you are you are you perceiving
because that has nothing to do with race
that has nothing to do with politics
your your awareness of that
i hear you
i hear you loud and clear brother
you